[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
[Musique]
mais la réunion nous les larmes même mis
mon pays comment il est la réunion
s'appelle miam parle pas moins les
misérables
en France rien que ça m'aime dépense
alors retrouve mon moment rien que la
même mot qui a des danses derrière elle
Lina la montagne
[Musique]
que je connais ça bonjour Bernard
Comment ça va ça va très bien alors
dites-moi qu'est-ce que tu regardes
au-dessus là mais je suis en train de
regarder le rempart du maldo qui a été
brûlé en novembre 2020 d'accord tout se
rempart a été parcouru par un grand
incendie qui a duré plusieurs jours et
qui a totalement déstabilisé les masses
rocheuses que l'on a au-dessus quand
j'ai passé sur le sentier là j'ai vu
qu'il y avait il y avait des travaux des
petits murets et là si je me tourne
là-bas pareil je vois aussi hop qui a
des qui a eu des travaux oui alors là
c'est une partie du sentier qui a été
très déstabilisé lors des incendies par
des chutes de rochers des rochers qui
sont descendus de plusieurs centaines de
mètres de haut donc qui ont cassé
carrément le sentier que l'on a
reconstruit et puis qui ont à nouveau
été complètement détruit avec des
cyclones de février 2022 ces travaux là
ont été faits en septembre
septembre 2022
avec des techniques
qui sont alpines
qu'on utilise dans les Alpes pour créer
un sentier c'est un sentier totalement
artificiel qui a été créé pour permettre
à nouveau le passage des habitants de
rocheplates des orangers et puis des
sportifs des touristes et de façon que
cet ouvrage là puisse résister oui à
l'avenir au futur chutes de pierre et
tout a été construit à la même tout a
été amené en hélicoptère et avec une
sécurité renforcée c'est à dire il
fallait que les ouvriers soient assurés
pour ne pas tomber on avait maître de
ville en dessous du chantier
effectivement on voit le vide d'accord
bon bah en tout cas merci bien moi j'ai
une escarroche pas tu es encore loin
maintenant ou pas
salut les gars
première fois première fois ici donc tu
viens découvrir un peu alors c'est
comment magnifique
exceptionnel les vues les panoramas et
en plus le temps le temps aujourd'hui
nous l'a commandé plus aux autres c'est
beau ben là 14 jours on n'a pas le temps
de tout leur montrer donc il faut garder
un peu pour la prochaine fois alors ou
pas la bonne salade souvent nous dit la
réunion les vite fait le tour
avec ça le monde qui dit ça c'est exact
les pas parti aventurer un peu dans le
cœur de Lille puisque on a toujours pu
découvrir on a toujours de surprises en
tout cas elle est bien Gaïa mais merci
azottes
allez bye bye
alors mais regarde ma montre au bout de
deux heures et demie de marche mais
arrive au lieu-dit La Brèche alors la
brèche regarde ça ici nous les a 1000
295 mètres d'altitude et bien évidemment
à droite nous ça va roche pas une
destination nous hein Roche Plate n'est
pas là que ça doit un petit peu ici
le Bronchard chinois bien là-bas l'autre
côté dessus la nouvelle et sinon à tonne
est encore là-bas d'un trou là-bas hop
normal et ben nous nous continuons
jusqu'à les lettres de roche plate allez
allons-nous
ah ok ben voilà nous là arriverons je
passe au bout de trois heures ok ben moi
je suis pas dans le caution
une école d'ailleurs il y en a moins de
10 mailles 8 exactement on a aussi
indispensaire un petit boutique et ben
nous nous ça a continué notre petite
balade dans Roche Plate allez
allons-nous
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]